[Music]
in these last three years we were told
stay in your house and don't go outside
don't go to work don't see your family
on Thanksgiving and Christmas Even
divorced parents couldn't transfer the
kids between households because that
would be two households getting together
I mean the The Madness of this science
fiction movie
um given the fact that people love
freedom so much is a really interesting
thing for us to reflect on as a society
how did we do that how did we have that
Constitution
that when we got away from the British
we basically said to the king you can't
come in my house without permission a
normal king would say I beg your pardon
you're my subject that's my house you're
talking about but America took this
different approach and wrote this
extraordinary document and others the
Constitution being one of them and I
think if you
if you look at world history which is
what I tend to do when I look at human
behavior you have a pie chart
almost all of that pie chart is tyranny
as a leadership strategy for human
beings and only this tiny tiny sliver is
the United States and Western Europe and
Australia and New Zealand in the back in
the day that really focused on the
freedom of the individual and that built
a whole society around that we must
never assume that's going to last
because again pie chart all tyranny just
this tiny sliver tyranny is actually the
more normal way of course for human
leadership to work leadership's not even
the right word uh you know domination
that is the more normal way and so in my
work the looking at predicting human
behavior I could I looked at this right
at the beginning these lockdowns for
example and I said all right we're being
asked to fear something so let me study
what it is that we're being asked to
fear because fear is a control mechanism
sometimes it's true the beginning of the
pandemic I'm like everybody else we only
knew two metrics over 60 die that's all
we knew about coven that's all we were
told so I'm like everybody else so wash
off the deliveries coming into the house
you can touch the pizza box but you
can't touch oh you can touch the pizza
but you can't touch the Box you got to
wipe it all the madness that went on but
I only had that information was it worth
stopping the planet Earth for it wasn't
turns out it wasn't did people die from
covet absolutely did fit healthy young
people die from covet no didn't happen
very very rare and usually with kids who
were hospitalized for other things so I
looked at that and I and bring it back
to the point you were raising about
about fear and prediction
governments throughout human history use
fear to control their citizens
Gavin de Becker remember that name you
can stream that conversation right now
on Fox Nation subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight